we just got proof that I was pregnant I
died to get my prenatal pills so we went
to Rite Aid the Caucasian man walks up
pushes dante's into a show and runs
through the store screaming he's got a
gun he's gonna kill him those love my
life I'm always will be
it was just soil was still fairly bright
we come out to store a hot car purchase
you hurt me but it has it and he
wouldn't because he was telling them I
didn't do anything can I talk to you
personally he was asking to speak to
them and they tried to tase him so he
went I'm walking in the street and I
start to see the helicopter I hear bed I
turn around and he's running to me he
grabs my right arm his hands about my
arm and they just start shooting him
they ripped me off of him laid him on
the ground full of bullet holes and
cuffed him like he was going somewhere
we're confused and that confusion leads
us to believe that we're in crisis then
when we feel we're in crisis we become
afraid that when we're afraid we don't
talk to each other we don't talk to each
other that we become very pond rockers
they're very separate this is in the
phobia world feels like shit telling
apart the whole fabric of human
existence yet we live in the most
connected time we've ever lived I
consider myself a representative of the
city engages the public and help people
in those communities understand the
power that they have to mold and shape
the city I don't think there's been an
increase unjustified use of force by the
LAPD I think there's more attention to
contacts that end up being negative in
Los Angeles we have historic close in
crime yet these incidents seem to be
prevalent they're part of the American
landscape now there are times we do some
things in law enforcement where we're
just straight wrong and what we have
today that we didn't have 20 years ago
is a communication system that brings it
all together and makes it seem like law
enforcement across this entire country
are corrupt brutal lying thugs and that
simply is not true
[Music]
so the most influential and significant
stakeholders in this community we're
here today to talk about some of the
issues that are going on in our
community and nationally and in how we
can respond in those issues which I have
information except you're gonna I'm not
gonna panic when you see a second person
example somebody I would argue that the
solutions begin with you it's up to our
faith-based leaders our educators our
parents there's a very difficult time
for that police similarity which has to
do with instantaneous decisions you'll
see how difficult it is
respond
them some commands there's a guy now in
the back you guys are now my use of
force review boy they're just involved
in a shooting so you're going to be part
of this decision process this is what
happens after you involve in an action
we're going to interview you over and
over and okay we got no everything you
just you just shot a man police officers
are the only ones who have the authority
to use force up to and including killing
somebody without any kind of due process
just objectively reasonable force based
on the conditions what kind of situation
did you have robbery suspect is it
likely robbery suspects gonna be armed
most likely most likely what happened
when you encounter ran toward us and
that's a huge piece of power it takes a
while for you to learn how to manage
that power does that bag likely because
great bottle Andrea done randomly
injured that broken bones or death no no
do you think you were authorized of
shooting yeah yeah I can tell you within
our policy we would not be on fish
in that situation he is not a deadly
threat he is a threat you have a right
to use force but is it what our policy
cover the use of deadly force for that
we've seen really great conversations
come out of those community training
days because it surprises people how
quickly things evolve and they use a
force situation something happens
instantaneously and you have to decide
in a split second what you need to do
every officer put in that situation is
going to react differently based on
their comfort level we hire from the
human race you don't have him and we're
all trained we all get the same training
but everybody's individual perception is
going to be different I was raised by a
stepfather who at times was very abusive
to my mother physically abusive I had to
call the police as a young kid and have
the police help her help me as a child
get out of harm's way the community is
only going to call you in an emotional
situation right they would have done it
but there are times when they really
need you to respond officers that are
there to help them that are there to
protect them
that's one of the things that made me
want to be a police officer how will
this profession changing officer Hickman
man this profession change you both with
your relationships with the current
family members or your spouse they can
take a toll on you as well as your
family I'm also if you ever have to take
someone's life that will definitely
stress you out as an individual we will
change the way we present ourselves to
the public
and then duty in Ostia together because
people will scrutinize your behavior
very differently that headline looks
very different LAPD officer does right
our society has a different standard for
different people so we kind of have to
accept that and recognize that's part of
the responsibility of this job we have
to find a way to prepare people for the
most horrible horrific situations and
yet keep their humanity it's unrealistic
to think that an officer because it took
a training is going to now go OK I'm
free God thank goodness
I took that training because now I'm
free of bias
[Music]
the reason we're standing here today
approximately 24 hours after this tragic
incident it's so hard it's so hard
because all you can say is I am so sorry
and that's all you could say to anyone
who lost anybody they loved
I think empathy is the engine to do this
work the pain is that empathy is not a
practice of government in general and so
the way this whole system is set up it
causes the rift between the police and
the community ratings man is number 621
this is 620 first person killed by fire
course in the LA County since 2000 so
our first question is when are we going
to give you these to us who's
responsible for each of these killings
and line of them have been investigated
and prosecuted
how many only be the officers in Europe
wearing and body cameras tonight
sometimes we have to be the punching bag
we signed up for this job we'll take it
we have to because sometimes you just
have to be there and be there what am I
gonna tell my kids growing up here stay
away from please and look at you I'm
freaked out I'm scared I don't want to
go and talk to you about the guy pushing
me in the face on the plot I'm gonna go
and find somebody that I know now you
you guys are gonna fucking find
something wrong with me find something a
charge before something wrong with the
way that I look I have to recognize
where we've been where the history of
our communities have been and sometimes
we have really hurt each other and
sometimes law enforcement has been used
as a tool to do that the two officers
that shot him
walked up to me after court and actually
apologized even they were like damn we
took this kid's father from them and we
didn't mean to like we're sorry so it
kind of brought some kind of closure it
helps a little bit but
[Music]
a question for you you like the police
the bad P be bad they kill they kill
people how you feel about them killing
your daddy not very good if we don't
have engagement with each other in
constructive ways then we will continue
to be in the same place and fifty years
from now we'll be talking about the same
things
[Music]
these Street in West seven people Street
West 7 am able to gun was shots fired at
these Street and west of it